to prove their batteries are reliable in
freezing temperatures Canadian Tire
built a truck out of 11,000 pounds of
ice and burrito box is the world's first
burrito kiosk that serves five different
types of burritos at the touch of a
button Vsauce Kevin here this is mind
blow the Skycycle is an urban concept
that would allow people to ride their
bikes in the sky developed by architect
Sir Norman Foster it would consist of
220 kilometres of safe car free bike
routes above London and include 200
different entry and exit points
accommodate 12,000 cyclists per hour and
improved bike travel time by almost 30
minutes budgie is a robot designed to
help with everyday tasks and to carry
around your stuff created by five
elements robotics it can hold up to 50
pounds and collapses easily for
transportation with a six to eight hour
battery life it's intended for a wide
range of uses from helping the elderly
and disabled to carrying around all your
stuff at an amusement park or mall sea
stars are able to see images with tiny
eyes located at the ends of their legs
that can be cut off and regenerate so
yeah pavegen is making energy out of
footsteps by transferring the kinetic
energy from a human step into renewable
electricity that can be stored for
future use
the titles are waterproof durable and
made from recycled materials so they can
easily cover existing high foot traffic
areas currently their largest permanent
installation is at Kent Grammar School
where 24 kinetic tiles cover about five
meters of corridor a new adhesive
activated by UV light is being developed
to repair holes in blood vessels and the
walls of the heart until now medical
adhesive glues were not able to
withstand the pressure that a beating
heart exerts and didn't adhere well to
wet tissue but by studying the viscous
secretions of slugs and sandcastle worms
researchers were able to figure out how
to form stable bonds underwater Corning
Gorilla Glass
created the world's first antimicrobial
cover glass for mobile devices it's
formulated to protect touch surfaces
from the growth of algae mold mildew
fungi and bacteria and works continually
over the entire life of the device
Aurora is a headband that claims to let
you control your dreams
it plays special lights and sounds when
you're in the REM cycle of sleep that
are supposed to induce lucid dreaming
the software and the headband senses
when you're dreaming by measuring brain
wave and eye movement activity the user
is able to pick out their own specific
dream signs which are used to induce the
lucid dreaming by making you aware of
your surroundings it also sets a smart
alarm clock that will wake you during
your most refreshed cycle of sleep
mother monitors small connected sensors
to make your everyday routines easier
motion cookies can be attached to almost
anything including water bottles to
check if you're drinking enough water
toothbrushes to make sure everyone is
brushing or pill bottles so you don't
forget your medication then mother puts
all of the information into the Sense
board where you can then check out the
news of your daily life one wheel is a
self-balancing skateboard that makes you
feel like you're on a hoverboard it uses
gyro and accelerometer sensors to feed a
processor that determines the exact
speed to drive the motor based on how
you lean your body and because of the
self balancing abilities they say almost
anyone can learn to use it within
minutes the power lasts for four to six
miles and can reach up to twelve miles
per hour MIFF is a self balancing robot
that can be controlled by hand gestures
and/or your smart device MIPS can dance
race and battle each other they're
taking pre-orders right now and plan to
roll out in the spring of 2014
finally the waters of green stone by
nathan caso shows the changing
landscapes of new zealand over a
three-week period
I'm going to leave you with geometric
bubbles and as always thanks for
watching